hi my dear friends and welcome back to
boom today we grow romaine lettuce
[Music]
you
hi-yah today I'm very excited because
I'm gonna share with you a very easy
technique to grow lettuce even from the
letters that you buy from the
supermarket it's very easy very healthy
and he grows really quickly so let's get
to it
so in order to grow your letters from
the letters that you bought in the
supermarket you will need your romaine
lettuce
of course nice a cutting board one jar
or a total work I'm actually reusing a
memory jar to fix and
so as you can see this letters was cut
from the root here it has no roots here
but that's not a problem all you have to
do is keep this part from your letters
so we're gonna cut it now and I'll show
you how it goes okay so welcome to the
kitchen okay
we're gonna cut the letters at about
five centimeters from the end of the
letters and then you can say the rest in
the fridge after you close the end of
your letters you will have something
like this so as you can see you have the
ends here no roots there and what we're
gonna do now is use the toothpaste to
put in the letters so I'm gonna put one
here maybe another one right here
another one here and another words here
so we have four toothpicks just like
this and I'm gonna set it aside now
we're gonna use our jar so fill up the
tart with water all the way up now we're
gonna put the letters inside the jar it
makes sure that it's actually touching
the water I'm gonna fill it up a little
bit more all the way to the top so I
make sure that the water is actually
touching the letters mm-hmm now your
letters will need some sunlight to book
so make sure that you put the letters in
a place with a sunny window so it gets
lots of sunlight so you can grow quicker
[Music]
okay so as you can see this lettuce goes
really quickly remember to always change
the water every one or two days so you
keep it clear and clean now this lettuce
has been in water for about three weeks
and as you can see the leaves are big
and green I think when your letters gets
to this size this is the best time to
harvest and eat the leaves this is
because keeping in mind that this
lettuce is not getting as much
ingredients as she would get in the soil
the leaves are gonna start becoming more
bitter so the best time to eat this
lettuce is at this point I have read
that we can actually transplant this
lettuce to soil so she can get the
nutrients that she needs so I'm gonna
try it today I'm gonna try to transplant
this lettuce to soil and see if she
actually survived I hope that she does
and I'm gonna show you now how I'm gonna
transplant it soil and then I'm just
gonna show you the progress on my
Instagram account so let's hope it works
okay so let's get to transplanting
so first in this container I'm going to
put organic all-purpose soil now we are
going to make a hole further that is and
this will be about five centimeters we
take the toothpicks out like so and
we're going to put the letters inside
try to compress the soil guys look so
pretty and now I'm just going to water a
little bit so I make sure that the soil
is moist okay so our first transplanted
tennis is finally ready I will make sure
to share the progress video on Instagram
wish this beautiful that is look and
hopefully it survived of course if
you're going lettuce with me please make
sure to share with me on Instagram I
would love to see it and we will share
with the community if you're watching
this video life let's keep the chat
going over here and if you're watching
it afterwards thank you for being here
and please leave a comment I will make
sure to reply
[Music]
I'll show you what I do this is the lime
or lemon base recipe today I'm gonna
make it we're going to
[Music]
thank you so much for being here and
watching this video and as always I will
see you in the next one okay
[Music]